Hey everyone Diavolo here and
today were back at it with the
pinnacle of all domain videos. In this
we are going to cover all of the known
domains that have been introduced to
us or mentioned throughout the series.
A Domain Expansion is the most incomparable
technique of any jujutsu user. It is the peak
of their essence, all pulled forth and
imagined through an innate domain that
itself, is covered with a barrier to
construct it in a different space.
With Jujutsu sorcery hand signs,
words, dance and other forms of
expressions all expand the level to
which someone can manipulate cursed
energy. A domain expansion is expanded
through the use of one of these actions,
for example Mahito opens his mouth wide to perform
his, while Dagon forms a symbol on their torso.
(Coffin Of The Iron Mountain) First of the
domains that we see throughout the series,
Coffin Of The Iron Mountain is the special
grade disaster curse, Jogoat’s supreme art.
This fiery domain meticulously replicates
the inner sanctum of a roaring,
live volcano. Encased within an impenetrable
stone chamber, its colossal walls and floors
are riddled with gaping crevices that
gush forth copious amounts of molten
magma. This results in a temperature so
insanely hot, that any typical jujutsu
user would instantly succumb to spontaneous
combustion upon setting foot within the domain.
Fittingly dubbed the "Coffin of the Iron
Mountain," this a lethal type domain that
is a equipped with a guaranteed hit. To
activate the lethal sure hit technique,
the user can control with ease all
of the lava and molten rock flowing
around the inside of the domain, and
direct that towards their target.
(Unlimited Void) Seen right after
we witnessed the Iron Mountain,
Unlimited Void is one of, if not the
most advanced technique in the vast
arsenal of the Limitless. Due to being the
stronger and more refined of the two domain,
Gojo’s Unlimited Void easily overpowered
and suppressed the effects of Jogo’s.
When it comes to the effects of Unlimited
Void, this domain inserts the user and
their intended targets inside "Limitless Itself,"
a boundless void filled with infinite flowing
knowledge. Within this vast space, a constant
flow of complex information floods into the
minds of the targets, overwhelming them to the
extent that they become completely paralyzed.
The incapacitation of the target occurs due to
a unique phenomenon where the target is both
aware of everything and yet unable to perceive
or sense anything at the same time. It's as if
every action they've ever taken in their life
is repeatedly imposed upon them, causing them to
suffer a slow and inevitable demise. It's worth
noting that this effect doesn't impact the user
or anyone they are in physical contact with. So
if you were to be stuck in this domain, the only
way to survive would be getting ahold of Gojo or
repairing that destroyed brain of yours with RCT.
(Self Embodiment Of Perfection) Third up,
and nearing the final seconds of Mahito’s
battle against Nanami and Yuji, he was able
to discover something by using his death as
an inspiration. Opening his mouth, Mahito throws
up miniature gang sign hand seals formed by tiny
hands inside of his mouth to activate his Domain
Expansion, The Self Embodiment Of Perfection.
This infamous domain creates a vast, dark space
where Mahito's target encounters enormous hands
that come together to form a flower-like
shape. These giant hands are connected by
multiple arms, creating a net-like cage
that encircles Mahito's intended victim.
The Self-Embodiment of Perfection works by
amplifying the effectiveness of Mahito's
Cursed Technique, Idle Transfiguration and
ensuring it directly affects the target's
soul instantly. Being inside of the Self
Embodiment of Perfection is described as
feeling as if you're figuratively in the palm of
Mahito's. Due to how idle transfiguration works,
this Domain Expansion is an almost sure kill
type of domain expansion. The only way one
would survive, is if they had some form of ability
that allowed them to block damage to their soul.
One thing I wanna point out about
Domain Expansions. If given time,
a Domain user can easily decide
who is caught by their domain,
as we saw with Mahito’s first bout
against Yuji and Nanami. However though,
when the preparation time is extremely limited,
or the conditions changed, one cant specifically
chose who is caught by it. This here, can
lead to a few drawbacks of Mahito’s domain,
and if he does accidentally touch the wrong
soul, it can backfire with drastic consequences.
(Graveyard) Using its fingers to craft hand
signs, the Smallpox Deity can active their domain,
Graveyard and instantly trap an opponent
inside. As the name suggests, the domain
itself is just a graveyard. What's special
about it though is how it plays on the curses
innate Gravestone Technique. Due to a domain
usually being granted with an automatic-hit,
Graveyard enhances the cursed technique and
automatically traps the opponent with the
highest cursed energy output in a coffin. Then,
once the conditions are fulfilled it guarantee’s
that the person will be infected with smallpox
and die. These conditions are that the curse
has to count down from 3, if it reaches one,
then it wins. If someone escapes the coffin,
it can continuously use this sure hit
technique over and over again. On top of that,
the gravestone itself deals critical
damage when putting someone underground.
(Chimera Shadow Garden) Next up and I
somehow initially forgot that we saw
Megumi’s first use of his domain during
the last few moments during season 1.
Although not fully able to be constructed
inside a sphere, Chimera Shadow Garden
when expelled in an environment that allows
it, saturates the surroundings with dense,
shadowy liquid. This allows any user
of the Ten Shadows Technique to summon
multiple shikigami at once and have free
manipulation over all shadows in the area.
Additionally, it brings forth a
sizable structure resembling two
columns of spinal bone interconnected
by some form of nerve endings. However,
this object vanishes shortly after
the initial activation of the domain.
Anyone standing in the shadow will have to
reinforce their feet with cursed energy or
risk falling into the abyss, this includes the
user themselves. Within the liquid-like shadows,
there is no buoyancy, resistance, or
oxygen. Anyone who has dropped into
it will fall indefinitely. AAAAAAND I
WONDER WHERE MEGUMI CURRENTLY IS....
(Horizon Of The Captivating Skandha)
Dagon's Domain Expansion, Horizon Of
The Captivating Skandha is activated
like I said earlier in the video,
with a seal on his stomach. This results
in the creation of a serene tropical beach
type domain. This domain is often described as
peaceful, and the water near the beach is shallow
enough for someone to stand in. This domain did
actually make an appearance during season 1,
however it was only for a moment, while
Dagon was still in his cursed womb state.
Within the Horizon of the Captivating Skandha,
Dagon's innate technique that ensures the
shikigami crafted by him automatically strike
their designated target. From the perspective
of those being targeted, these fish-like
shikigami seemingly materialize out of nowhere,
making them exceptionally hard
to predict. This is because the
shikigami only come into existence at the
moment they make contact with the target.
One of the techniques inside of Dagon's domain
that takes advantage of this sure hit effect,
Death Swarm takes the form of large marine
like shikigami and has them constantly attack
until the opponent is devoured. The only
way to stop this endless sea of death is
to disrupt the cursed spirits domain and
glitch out the sure hit function of it.
(Malevolent Shrine) True to its name, the
Malevolent Shrine creates an area focused
around a small singular, altered Buddhist
shrine, that has been distorted to instead
enshrine demons. This shrine somewhat
resembles a Chinjudō and if you remember
back to where exactly Megumi was looking
for Sukuna’s finger during the early EP’s.
Anyways Anyways, Instead of the peaceful
picturesque shrines peaceful deities have,
Sukuna’s shrine (or the FREAKING KITCHEN as
someone at Crunchyroll decided to mess up),
is encircled by murky, dark-colored water, and
the ground is adorned with horned skulls. The
roof is embellished with protruding horns and
suspended human skulls. The four entrances to
the shrine take the form of large, grotesque
mouths, featuring humanlike teeth and tongues.
Unlike almost every other domain seen so far in
the series, Sukuna’s domain is built different.
Instead of imagining an innate environment
and surrounding it with a barrier to give
it structure. The KING of curses, Ryomen Sukuna is
equipped with a barrier-less domain. An art so far
beyond normal comprehension its as if someone is
painting in thin air without the use of a canvas.
The Malevolent Shrine's guaranteed-hit
ability enables it to ruthlessly slash
through anything within its effective
range until only dust remains. To do this,
Sukuna employs two types of slashing attacks,
namely his known and extremely trusty Cleave and
Dismantle. These two slicing attacks will not stop
slashing until the domain is disengaged or Sukuna
is too severely injured to sustain it any longer.
Sukuna has the capability to choose between these
two attacks based on the target type, opting for
Dismantle against inanimate objects and Cleave for
subjects with cursed energy. This is also how
Sukuna cuts the world for any one confused, he
uses dismantle to cut the world behind the
infinity. Get it? Also on top of that we’ve
seen Sukuna implement a few different conditions
into the structure of how his domain is formed.
For example during his battle against Gojo,
Sukuna’s domain grew beyond Unlimited Void's
barrier. With a domain's barrier being weak to
attacks on its outer shell, Gojo's domain was
crushed by Malevolent Shrine's slashing attacks
and he was immediately struck by its can't-miss
attack. Throughout that long battle, some of
the binding vows he placed apon his domain,
were like removing Malevolent Shrine's
guaranteed-hit effect within Unlimited
Void's effective area or narrowing down its
effective range, similar to when it was used in
Shibuya. In exchange Sukuna was granted increased
power to counter Gojo’s own domain improvisations.
I didnt mention those improvisations during
Gojo’s infinite void part of the video as
they technically qualify as binding vows
that I’ll stick in a binding vow video.
Seeing as were here now though... Simply Gojo
could do a bunch of similar improvisations,
like expanding the Domains Shell or reducing
the overall size of his domain expansion to
a basketball, something most
sorcerers deemed impossible.
(Deadly Sentencing) 7th of the known domains
that weve seen throughout the series,
comes from the first opponent our main
cast face’s during the culling game.
Hiromi Higuruma’s domain Deadly Sentencing
creates a large courtroom where the user
and their target stand across from one another
playing the roles of prosecutor and defendant.
Unlike most of the domains we’ve seen throughout
the series and just due to Higuruma learning the
use of his technique in private. Deadly Sentencing
is a type of domain that isn't considered lethal,
it can still be lethal in the end, but
it doesn't contain a cannot miss attack
like others. Way back in the early days of
Jujutsu discovery, like before even Sukuna,
a domain expansion wasn't used as a
finishing move, instead they forced
those who were caught inside to abide by the
rules or bindings of that domains technique.
Once caught inside of Deadly Sentencing,
the law type cursed technique imbued into
the domain allows the user to prosecute their
target with the shikigami called Judgeman.
Inside this domain, no physical violence
is permitted for either party. Initially,
Judgeman reveals the accusations against
the accused, which consist of real crimes
they may or may not have committed. Despite
Judgeman having access to all information
about everyone within the domain, this
knowledge is not given to the user.
In the trial, the final decision depends on what
each side says. After hearing the accusations,
the person being accused gets one shot to defend
themselves. They can choose to stay quiet,
admit guilt, or say they didn't do it. If they
deny it, they can even lie. The goal for the
accused person is to convince Judgeman
they're innocent and clear any doubts.
Once it's the prosecutor's turn in the Deadly
Sentencing, they get a single chance to speak.
Their statement is like a counterargument using
evidence given by Judgeman for review. The
evidence comes in a sealed envelope, held by the
prosecutor. The information inside isn't treated
as definite proof, and it stays closed until after
the prosecutor speaks, keeping the accused in
the dark. However, Judgeman shares the info with
the prosecutor as soon as they get the envelope.
After both the prosecutor and the defense have
had their say, Judgeman steps in to give a legal
verdict. If the accused is deemed guilty,
they face one of several possible sentences,
though the user isn't certain which one.
The severity of the punishment can vary,
with more serious crimes leading to
harsher penalties in certain cases.
Before the verdict is given, Judgeman often
dishes out a punishment called "Confiscation,"
which stops the guilty person from using
cursed techniques. Once the verdict is given,
the domain expansion disappears, and the
punishment takes effect on the guilty party
straight away. However, if the accused is
found guilty without openly admitting it,
they can ask for another trial,
and Judgeman has to agree. This
is called an appeal and even though
it hasn't specifically been stated,
im assuming someone has the right to at least 2
appeals, just like we do in most court systems.
(Idle Death Gamble) So... When it comes
to this next expansion, Idle Death Gamble,
we are prooobably gonna be here a while. This
technique is so hard for my small brain to
wrap itself around. It really is one of
the most mind boggling techniques seen
so far from jujutsu kaisen. Its not crazy,
blowing up cities level of mind boggling,
but Hakari just had to go and be a creative
genius with way to much time on his hands.
Firstly the full name for this
domain is Idle Death Gamble:
CR Private Pure Love Train Version 1/239. The CR
stands for Card Reader and its actually based on
a real pachinko machine, with obviously
the same name. Dude is a degenerative
manga reader or gambler, probably both.
The user's goal is to hit the jackpot by
lining up three of the same symbols decorated
with the characters of Private Pure Love Train.
There are 7 different characters in the private
pure love train series. Starting from the main
hero with the number 7, Yuki Yamaguchi. The Main
heroine and number 3, Yume Asagiri. Number 6 and
Yuki’s younger sister, Sayaka Yamaguchi. According
to info she pretends to be using an electronic
dictionary but is jamming on the DS instead.
Number 4 and the dude who cant tell the different
between a guitar and a bass, Hiro Kato. Yuki’s
current boss, by day she’s a project manager, but
when night arrives, damn gurl! The number 2 Sayuri
Amanogawa. Yuki’s current coworker and number 5,
Suzuka Shimizu. Then finally Number 1, Yuki’s
old friend and currently a bank thief, Aya Saito.
Now that the characters are all out of
the way, once a jackpot is achieved,
it grants the user unlimited cursed energy. Along
with that it gives them a fully automatic reversed
cursed technique that lasts for exactly 4 minutes
and 11 seconds. The reason for the length of the
technique is because the theme some for Private
Pure Love Train “Admiring You” runs for that time.
To hit the mentioned jackpot, the user needs to
engage actively in the game's dynamics, facing a
slim 1/239 odds. Once the domain is activated,
the rules of the game are instantaneously
transferred to the opponent's mind. This is done
through taking advantage of a domains sure hit
technique, so Hakari uses the sure hit to transfer
the rules and not to damage. As a trade-off,
the construction and infusion of cursed technique
into this domain happens unrealistically fast,
completing in less than 0.2 seconds. Man could
probably stop all those crafty 0.2 second domains
from Shibuya. Plus along that same line
of thinking, and just due to how quickly
he can throw up his gang signs, it makes this
domain extremely proficient in activating first.
Moving onto the dynamics of how the game works
inside of a domain. Initially once started,
the two opponents will both appear on a
neutral stage. Before they throw hands,
the user has the ability to create three
distinct visual effect indicators: shutter doors,
reserve balls, and consecutive effects. The
doors and balls serve as offensive maneuvers,
while consecutive effects act as defensive
indicators, rewinding a sequence to undo damage.
Doors and reserve balls come in a green, red,
or gold rarity to symbolize a higher chance at
a jackpot. Rainbow-colored indicators or re-doing
four consecutive effects guarantees a jackpot.
The user has the option to select
which visual indicator to generate,
but the outcome is left to chance. Creating one
or more visual indicators advances the stage to
a riichi scenario, unveiling two out of
three necessary numbers for a jackpot.
When it comes to this new thing I just brought up,
Riichi scenario’s. These are scenarios involving
the aforementioned characters from the pure
private love train pachinko machine. From what we
have seen, there are 4 different riichi sequences
with differing chances of hitting a jackpot. The
final train scenario is different though and
has an over 80% chance of jackpot. Each of the
sequences will change the layout of the domain,
changing it to resemble a different stage, then it
will use the characters of Private Pure Love Train
in a different way for that scene. Im not going to
go over the differing scenario’s in themselves
otherwise, oml we are gonna be here a while.
This is for fact that we haven't even
been able to discuss, what the hell
happens if Hakari fails to hit a jackpot.
Pretty much because, like a true gambler,
Hakari understands that the house always
wins. If someone fails to hit a jackpot,
then the scenario will revert the stage back to
its original form. This cycle continues until the
user either secures a victory or exhausts all
chances to do so, with the number of possible
attempts diminishing with each unsuccessful
jackpot. During the initial activation of
consecutive expansions, the likelihood of
hitting the jackpot exceeds twenty percent.
When a jackpot is achieved, the domain vanishes,
and “Admiring You“ begins its 4 minutes and 11
second counter, playing loudly around the user.
Like I mentioned to start with, the user receive
a bonus of unlimited cursed energy for the
entire duration of the song. This unrestricted
cursed energy comes with no limitations, )so
for those few minutes he’s considered special
grade) and the user can receive additional
bonus amounts at random intervals throughout
the round. This along with the automatic
use of RCT prevents the user's body from
sustaining damage and renders them effectively
invulnerable for four minutes and eleven seconds.
Once the song comes to an end, the user's
cursed energy returns to its normal level,
and their cursed technique is fully replenished.
This in turn allows them to activate their domain
repeatedly, on the condition that they achieve
a jackpot each time. With consecutive uses of
this domain, the conditions of the previous one’s
will still be active. If If the user aligns three
odd numbers, the stage begins with advanced
probability rather than the neutral state.
In the case of aligning even numbers, the stage
commences with faster spins. Meaning that he can
bring about a jackpot quicker, even with a less of
a percentage. Additionally, there's a possibility
for the stage to start in hidden probability mode.
This is taken directly from a pachinko machine and
is usually akin to faster spins but with an
elevated probability of hitting the jackpot.
Thats kind of everything we know about the domain
expansion. Its nice having the binding vow of
“showing ones hand”, means we all at some point
or another will get an explanation of an ability.
Unless the sorcerer is so much stronger, they
dont even need to mention it. Anyways Anyways!
(Time Cell Moon Palace) Professional
hater Naoya Zenin came back with one of
the craziest powerups in the series! His awe
inspiring Domain Expansion fittingly named,
Time Cell Moon Palace is my favorite
name for an ability seen in the series.
Unlike the previous few domains we’ve been over,
casting Naoya’s domain is pretty stock standard.
It creates a black empty environment, like most
other sorcerers, with a few floating organisms
seen about. In the center is a large main stage
that is made up of a flesh like substance. This
pathway leads down to a large eye that
is situated directly behind the caster.
The domain's auto-hit feature sends out an
injecting tape of animation frames that jabs
into the necks of its chosen targets. If anyone
makes a single movement inside of the domain,
they must adhere by the 24 FPS rule
of projection sorcerery. If they dont
follow those rules, then unlike the original
technique, they dont get stuck in a frame,
instead it will result in body
wide injuries on a cellular level.
Like most domains, Time Cell Moon Palace enhances
the accuracy of the embedded cursed technique,
honing in on individual cells. Freezing
these individual cells disrupts their
normal functioning, resulting in innumerable
tiny cuts across the entire body, rendering the
target immobile. Any attempt to force movement
may lead to the severing of an entire limb.
This is an extremely lethal domain, however
sadly for Naoya dude got hit by a building.
(Womb Profusion) Next up and second
to last in all of the known domains,
Womb Profusion is a terrifyingly deadly ability
in the hands of no one other than Kenjaku himself.
As we saw with Sukuna and just due to how
the battle was playing out against Yuki,
Kenjaku can expand his domain without
enclosing it inside of a barrier.
Im assuming that its also possible
for him to enclose it in a barrier,
but because of how Tengen was targeting
barriers, he purposely decided not to use one.
To activate this domain, the user places the
backside of their fingers together and interlocks
them. Enlarging this domain gives rise to a totem
like tower covered in grotesque, merged faces
resembling cursed spirits. Anyone ensnared
within the reach of its unavoidable strike
experiences an explosive impact akin to a direct
hit from Maximum: Uzumaki, although the specific
characteristics of this attack remain undisclosed.
Just because of the curse spirit styling of this
domain, I believe that its most likely the domain
Suguru could’ve achieved if he didnt pass on.
(Threefold Affliction) Last now of the known
domains inside of Jujutsu Kaisen. Yorozu’s
Threefold Affliction is not actually deadly
in itself, instead this domain’s sure-hit
effect works with the users constructed items
that they bring into the structure. Opening
this domain results in a predominantly empty
expanse, interspersed with oversized organic
structures suspended within it. Sticking with
Yorozu’s bug theme, these structures bear a
resemblance to the detached brains and spinal
nerve cords of insects. As I mentioned above,
the main feature of Threefold affliction is
bringing a construction into the domain, mainly
her perfect sphere creation. If this ability
enters the domain, it will result in her win.
So now that we’re at the end of what we’ve seen
domain wise, who do you think is going to be
next? If you were chucked into the world
of Jujutsu kaisen and had to choose one
domain type what would it be. No need to think on
cursed techniques, just domains, id love to know
down below. Me I wanna be different and I think
id take Kenjaku’s Womb Profusion, the domain just
seems insanely deadly and super unexplored which
I always love. That brings me to another point,
have you noticed how many of these domains
feature body parts? Its like domains imagine
a section of some imaginary beast and bring
it forth, then paste their technique onto it
in some way. I wonder if the culling game is
going to result in a merger of all of those
parts to create that monolithic creature Kenjaku
wants to bring to life. So much I wanna know and
its why I love this series, if you have enjoyed
the video and found it insightful, feel free to
leave a like as it really helps with pushing my
content to a bunch of new amazing people. Plus
if you are new around here and want to watch more
content like this, then subscribe! Either way for
not its been your professional degenerate
Diavolo and ill see you all in a bit bye!